so it's been confirmed a um further 14
cases which now takes the total of the
UK up to 71. and what can you tell us
about these new cases that have been
identified
so we are I'm seeing further um
identification amongst most cases
um and that's because we're actively
looking for monkey false cases
um working with the NHS
um and with um uh third sector charity
Partners to encourage people with
symptoms to present
um and that means as we identify uh
cases and the contacts that gives us the
best possible chance to control this
transmission so this increase in cases
we will continue to see over the next
few days as we continue to actively look
for them uh yeah we're talking about it
a lot in the news so people are aware of
it we understand that the risk to The
Wider public is low however
um we've heard a lot of talk
particularly during the coronavirus
pandemic about contact tracing and
contact tracing is being talked about
when it comes to Monkey pox as well it's
helping you to do your job and identify
cases quickly in that respect are we any
closer to identifying The Source the
source of the monkey pox that came into
the UK
so in our contact tracing we're looking
at both
um the forward contact tracing to
identify people who
um the case may have passed monkey box
onto but we're also doing was sometimes
backwards contact tracing trying to
identify the sources of this and be able
to understand those trends of
transmission so we can try and
interrupt them
and part of that is not just working in
the UK but it's also working with our
International Partners
um uh in Europe and across the world to
try and understand those um full chains
of transmission to share the information
that we're all Gathering the evidence
that we're all building
um so we can control this but in all of
this key is making sure that people do
come forward so um we are encouraging
anybody with an unusual rash or a
Leisure on any part of their body to
contact nhs11 or their local Sexual
Health Service yeah um important to look
forward in terms of obviously you don't
want onward spread but as you said
important to look back as well how far
back have you traced monkeypox in terms
of finding the original Source because
there has been talk about a festival
somewhere in Europe that may have been
an original Super spreader event how far
back have you traced monkey pox have you
found it to have originated at a
festival level
so we are currently um following up all
of these um cases
um working back
um through the chains of transmission
and trying to understand common points
um there may be more than one
sourceified transmission but this is key
to actually building up that information
um yeah so I'm just I'm just interested
how far back you've been able to trace
it because people will be interested if
they travel to a festival in Europe
um you know a few weeks ago if they were
there they'd want to know to know if
they were at risk so I'm just trying to
get to the bottom of how far back you've
traced it so far
so
um we're continuing with our efforts to
that contact tracing and um as we know
more we can um share um that risk in
information
um but part of that is making sure we
have got that full picture and we have
picked up those
um all of those cases and it's not just
um what we can do is actually pulling
that information with our European
Partners
um so we can have the the full
understanding okay let's talk about the
um 71 confirmed cases are all the cases
adults uh there has been a report that
there is a child who has monkey pox and
is in intensive care can you give us an
update on that
so I'm not going to go into details of
the individual cases
um a notable proportion of the cases
identified
um to dates have been amongst um gay and
bisexual men so we are asking
um uh them in particular to be very
aware of the symptoms and to present to
sexual health clinics
um if they develop them
um can we talk about
um
how certain you are that there has been
no change to the virus that has made it
more transmissible we talk about
mutations of viruses and obviously
monkeypox is new to a number of
countries including the UK outside of
Africa have you done full genetic
sequencing yet on this
so we are undertaking sequencing on the
virus um and equally um this is um being
done internationally with
um other countries sequencing
um and that will allow us to compare it
to previous sequences
um uh both from the UK and and elsewhere
but all what we're seeing at the moment
is con um system with transmission from
very
um
close
um contact Direct contact so that's our
the focus of our work and our control at
the moment
um can you put this into context for us
um we understand that case numbers are
still relatively low the risk of the
general public is low it's important to
stress that but it monkeypox has been
mentioned at a G7 meeting of Health
ministers why the concern can you talk
to people about you know can you
reassure them we're not on the verge of
another pandemic this has been described
as containable but what if it's not
so this is the first occasion we've seen
spread in the UK that we can't rapidly
link back to endemic countries in West
and central Africa but this is very
different from
um covid or other pandemic illnesses
um the transmission that we are seeing
here is from close direct contact in
particular with the lesions or the scabs
from the lesions so we are seeing
um those uh spread like that which is
very different from what we see in
um uh other analysis so the overall risk
the population is low we're going to
continue to investigate and control this
um
and keep people updated